[Music]
we were told to expect vintage Joe Biden
and the president Drew deeply on the
past to make a heartfelt plea for
Freedom From the Past of the city where
he was standing
knowing what you stand for is most
important and knowing who stands with
you makes all the difference
the people of Paul know that you know
that
in fact you know you know it better than
anyone here in Poland because that's
what solidarity means
to the present the moment we're now in
and its importance for the future
As We Gather tonight
the world and my viewers and at an
inflection point
the decisions we make over the next five
years or so are going to determine and
shape our lives for decades to come
it's true for Americans it's true for
the people of the world
and while decisions
are ours to make now
the principles and the stakes are
eternal but he acknowledged the
challenges ahead in keeping the alliance
together one year into this war
Putin no longer doubts the strength of
our coalition
but he still doubts our conviction
he doubts our staying power
he doubts our continuous support for
Ukraine
he doubts whether NATO can remain
Unified
but there should be no doubt our support
you for Ukraine will not waver NATO will
not be divided and we will not Tire
this was Joe Biden the Statesman and
Cold War Warrior whose lifelong Battle
For Freedom had taken him all the way to
war-torn Kiev this week
Jay Barnett's Mission now is to Rally
the Allies to maintain the unity they
have shown for a year to the surprise of
many but there are differences between
them over how fast to arm Ukraine and
over what kind of Victory they want to
impose on Russia
earlier President Biden met his polish
counterparts who want stronger support
for Ukraine he'll meet other allies
tomorrow
in Joe Biden's audience we'd found
ukrainians Julia and her mother Julia's
brother is fighting in back much she
told me the Americans have put on a
beautiful show she said but a country
needs more if it was the first day over
it will be okay today one year well I
think it's not enough
too much time we wait too much time
Ukraine's government also wants more
help faster but some allies are worried
about giving too much too soon the
President's challenge is maintaining
unity and momentum as this conflict
enters another year Dominic wagorn Sky
News Warsaw